[Applause]
an even greater threat to the south of
Italy than this virus could be unrest
it's hard to watch but this is what
desperation looks like this man in
Apulia shouting at police that his
family have no money
[Music]
his mother almost crying she begs them
to come home to see they have no food a
photo has emerged of police descending
on a supermarket in Sicily it's claimed
they were called to restore control
after people came to steal food luckily
this father in Palermo posted a video
message to the Prime Minister showing
his daughter eating some bread it's been
shared around the country say coming
here via RT bambini try what get German
or das Konoha I'm Angela stupid sediba
Hannah certain Queen locally nonsan esta
casa censors demos to be fashionable
Jonas the Prime Minister has made 25
billion euros available for families and
businesses affected by lockdown some say
they're still waiting for that help
others don't qualify because their
employment isn't officially recorded
Italy has a big cash economy the
majority of this is in the south of the
country and the further south you go the
higher the deprivation the higher the
unemployment while the virus hasn't
reached the same crisis level down here
hardship and hunger threatened to be
even bigger problems in the last few
days people have started organizing
raids of supermarkets enclosed groups on
social media a video shared with us from
Sicily claims this man is even offering
to kill the mayor of Palermo says crime
gangs are exploiting the situation and
inciting violence he warns a social
emergency is next
I weep Okies phone mr. about the Seebeck
rock sorry this was your last show then
get in order [ __ ] police will surely as
hundreds continue to die each day hope
and patience are fading to this small
town in Lombardy is burying 90 of its
citizens with the aid of the military
perhaps no more stark reminder lockdown
is needed to save lives but in the south
it feels like it's threatening their
very survival
Sally Lockwood Sky News Rome